You know what's weird about the presidency? Or, you know, one of the things that's weird? They all have to live in the same house-- all the presidents. You ever think about that? OK, when you win the Super Bowl-- if the Patriots won the Super Bowl the previous year, you don't go and live in Bill Belichick's house. You don't drink coffee every morning in his kitchen, watch TV in his rec room at night. That would be strange. It's so personal living in somebody's space.
你知道总统这个职位有什么奇怪的地方吗？或者说，你知道其中一个奇怪的地方是什么吗？他们都必须住在同一所房子里——所有的总统都一样。你有没有想过这个问题？好吧，当你赢得超级碗时——如果爱国者队在前一年赢得了超级碗，你不会去住进比尔·贝里奇克的家里。你不会每天早上在他的厨房喝咖啡，晚上在他的娱乐室看电视。那会很奇怪。住进别人的空间是一件非常私人的事情。
Think of President Trump. For so many years, he said Barack Obama shouldn't be president, said he wasn't born in the United States. He's still picking fights with Barack Obama today. There was that White House Correspondents' Dinner that Trump attended back when Obama was President.
想想特朗普总统。多年来，他一直说贝拉克·奥巴马不应该担任总统，说他不是在美国出生的。直到今天，他还在和贝拉克·奥巴马吵架。当年奥巴马担任总统时，特朗普曾参加过那场白宫记者协会晚宴。
Donald Trump is here tonight.
唐纳德·特朗普今晚就在这里。
Where Obama mocked him.
奥巴马在晚宴上嘲笑了他。
All kidding aside, obviously we all know about your credentials and breadth of experience.
不开玩笑了，显然我们都知道你的资历和丰富的经验。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
For example-- no, seriously. Just recently in an episode of Celebrity Apprentice, at the steakhouse, the men's cooking team--
例如——不，说真的。就在最近的一集《名人学徒》中，在牛排馆里，男士烹饪团队——
Then Trump wins the White House and moves in and has to sleep in Barack Obama's old bedroom, uses the same bathroom in the morning. And at least at the beginning, they must picture the previous guy there. Right? Now and then? OK, at least once? It's weird that we make the most powerful man in the world do this-- sleep in the bedroom of somebody he might hate, somebody he might really see as an enemy. But, you know, that's a peaceful transfer of power.
然后特朗普赢得了白宫并搬了进去，不得不睡在贝拉克·奥巴马曾经的卧室里，每天早上用同一个浴室。至少在最初，他们一定会想象前任住在那里的样子，对吧？时不时地？好吧，至少一次？我们让世界上最有权力的人做这件事——睡在他可能憎恨的人，或者他可能真正视为敌人的人的卧室里，这很奇怪。但是，你知道，这就是权力的和平交接。
I hope it's not too partisan say a few kind words today about the peaceful transfer of power from one president to the next. We all still believe in that, right? Republicans and Democrats? We all stand by this basic principle of our Constitution and our democracy?
我希望今天说几句关于从一任总统向下一任总统和平交接权力的好话，不会显得太偏袒。我们大家都仍然相信这一点，对吧？共和党人和民主党人？我们都支持我们宪法和民主的这一基本原则，对吧？
In 1992, Bill Clinton defeated the incumbent president, George HW Bush. Bush had to move out of the White House for the young president who'd sent him packing. Bush left this letter for Clinton in the Oval Office. It's been circulating around on the internet this week. The original is handwritten on White House stationery. It reads--
1992年，比尔·克林顿击败了在任总统乔治·H·W·布什。布什不得不搬出白宫，让位给那位让他卷铺盖走人的年轻总统。布什在椭圆形办公室给克林顿留下了这封信。这封信本周在互联网上流传。原件是手写在白宫信笺上的。信中写道——
"Dear Bill, when I walked into this office just now, I felt the same sense of wonder and respect that I felt four years ago. I know you will feel that too. I wish you great happiness here. I've never felt the loneliness some presidents have described. There will be very tough times made even more difficult by criticism you may not think is fair. I'm not a very good one to give advice, but just don't let the critics discourage you or push you off course.
“亲爱的比尔，当我刚才走进这间办公室时，我感受到了四年前同样的惊奇和敬意。我知道你也会有这种感觉。我祝愿你在这里生活得非常幸福。我从未感受到一些总统所描述的那种孤独感。会有非常艰难的时刻，而你可能认为不公平的批评会使这些时刻变得更加困难。我不善于提供建议，但请不要让批评者使你灰心或让你偏离航向。”
You'll be our president when you read this note." He underlines the word "our." "I wish you well. I wish your family well. Your success now is our country's success. I'm rooting hard for you. Good luck. George."
“当你读到这张便条时，你就是我们的总统了。”他在“我们的”这个词下画了横线。“祝你好运。祝你的家人一切顺利。你现在的成功就是我们国家的成功。我全心全意地支持你。祝你好运。乔治。”
I know two people who cried when they read that this week. That's how far that letter seems from the America we live in right now. I like it that we make the new president go and sleep in the bedroom of his vanquished rival. I like how intimate that is, you know? What's more intimate than your own bedroom? I think it underlines how we're all stuck with each other in this country, divided as we are, disagreeing so vehemently. It underlines how we can't get away from each other.
我知道有两个人本周读到这封信时哭了。这封信似乎与我们现在所生活的美国相去甚远。我喜欢我们让新总统去睡在他被击败的对手的卧室里这一点。你知道，我喜欢这种亲密感吗？还有什么比你自己的卧室更私密的呢？我认为这强调了在这个国家里，我们所有人是如何被困在一起的，尽管我们四分五裂，争论得如此激烈。这强调了我们是如何无法摆脱彼此的。
Today in our program, "Same Bed, Different Dreams," you'll hear stories of enemies sleeping together, or working together, or just stuck together in some way with very different hopes and goals. We have stories of deception and star-crossed haters. From WBEZ Chicago, this is This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天我们的节目主题是“同床异梦”，你将听到一些关于敌人睡在一起、一起工作，或者以某种方式被困在一起，但怀有截然不同的希望和目标的故事。我们有关于欺骗和受苦的仇恨者的故事。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, "Dream Weevil." That title is going to make more sense as this story goes on. Just trust me on that.
第一幕，“梦想编织者”。随着故事的展开，这个标题会变得更有意义。相信我。
In 1986, a man and woman ran into a US Embassy in Vienna and said they needed asylum. They were from South Korea. And they told embassy officials this incredible story of kidnapping, and intrigue, and being torn apart and thrown back together, and years of dreaming about escape from their kidnapper, while, at the same time, convincing their kidnapper that what they really wanted to do was stay with him. Nancy Updike has the story.
1986年，一名男子和一名女子跑进维也纳的美国大使馆，称他们需要庇护。他们来自韩国。他们向大使馆官员讲述了一个关于绑架、阴谋的故事，关于被拆散又被强行凑到一起，以及多年来梦想着从绑架者手中逃脱，同时又必须让绑架者相信他们真正想做的是留在他身边。南希·厄普代克带来了这个故事。
The woman who was kidnapped was a famous South Korean actress named Choi Eun-Hee. I read a book about it by a writer and film producer named Paul Fischer. He spent years researching this story.
被绑架的女性是一位著名的韩国女演员，名叫崔银姬。我读过一位名叫保罗·费舍尔的作家和电影制片人写的关于这件事的书。他花了多年时间研究这个故事。
She was compared, at the time, to Elizabeth Taylor.
当时她被比作伊丽莎白·泰勒。
Elizabeth Taylor. Imagine if Elizabeth Taylor, past her prime but still famous from all her iconic roles, had just disappeared one day. Choi was that beautiful, that much of an icon in South Korea, and she was gone. She found out pretty quickly who had arranged this.
伊丽莎白·泰勒。想象一下，如果伊丽莎白·泰勒虽然过了巅峰期，但仍然因为她所有的标志性角色而家喻户晓，却突然有一天消失了。崔在韩国就是那么美丽，那么具有偶像地位，而她就这样消失了。她很快就发现了是谁策划了这一切。
When Choi was kidnapped in 1978, she was put on a boat, and the boat went to Namp'o Harbor in North Korea. And she actually has a photo, which is in the book, of her very first meeting with Kim Jong-il. He was there waiting for her off the boat with a photographer. And he had his photographer take a photo and then send it to her as a sort of--
崔在1978年被绑架时，她被送上一艘船，船开往朝鲜的南浦港。书里有一张照片，记录了她与金正日的第一次会面。他当时就在船外等着她，还带着摄影师。他让摄影师拍了一张照片，然后把它作为一种——
You'll want to remember this.
你会想记住这一刻的。
Exactly. Remember that time.
没错。记住那个时候。
Remember that time I had you kidnapped and brought to me?
记住我把你绑架并带到我身边的那次吗？
And it's a terrible picture. And he's beaming and smiley, and she's got her face covered.
那是一张糟糕的照片。他笑容满面，而她却遮住了脸。
For years, her family and her country didn't know where she was. This happened in 1978. Choi was in her 50s. And her first sickening guess as to why she'd been taken was that Kim Jong-il had brought her to North Korea to be a mistress for his father, the Great Leader, Kim Il-sung, who was ruling the country at the time.
多年来，她的家人和她的国家都不知道她在哪里。这件事发生在1978年。崔当时50多岁。她对被带走原因的第一个令人作呕的猜测是，金正日把她带到朝鲜是为了给他的父亲，当时统治这个国家的伟大领袖金日成做情妇。
But no, it seemed that Kim Jong-il himself was just a very big fan of Choi's movies. He put her up in a fancy villa, surrounded by walls and barbed wire and armed guards. She called it, in her memoir, "Las Vegas meets Vladivostok." Kim Jong-il brought her out to display at parties. That was Choi's life for five years, until one particular night and one special party.
但不是，看来金正日本身就是崔的电影的超级粉丝。他把她安置在一栋豪华别墅里，周围有围墙、铁丝网和武装警卫。她在回忆录中称之为“拉斯维加斯遇见符拉迪沃斯托克”。金正日把她带出来在派对上展示。这就是崔五年的生活，直到某个特定的夜晚和一场特殊的派对。
Choi had been there for a while. And she was standing somewhere in the center of the room.
崔在那里住了一段时间。她站在房间中央的某个地方。
And she was used to these parties by this point.
到那时，她已经习惯了这些派对。
Exactly. They were routine. She'd started feeling repulsed by them. People got drunk and groped women, and then they went on forever. And somebody had already told her that, this is going to be such a great evening for you. And she nodded along, because she was used to hyperbole about everything.
没错。它们已经成了家常便饭。她开始对这些派对感到厌恶。人们喝醉了，猥亵女性，而且这些派对没完没了。有人已经告诉她，今晚对你来说会是一个很棒的夜晚。她点头附和，因为她习惯了对一切事物的夸大其词。
Choi had no idea that Kim Jong-il that night was planning to show off, for the first time, another person he had acquired, the man who had directed or produced almost all of Choi's movies, her ex-husband, Shin Sang-Ok. Shin and Choi each didn't know that the other was also in the country. Shin had been brought the same way Choi was. But he tried to escape twice, so he was thrown in a prison camp for a couple of years.
崔根本不知道金正日那天晚上计划第一次炫耀他获得的另一个人——那个几乎执导或制作了崔所有电影的前夫，申相玉。申和崔都不知道对方也在这个国家。申被带来的方式和崔一样。但他试图逃跑两次，所以被关进了劳改营几年。
The best way to describe Shin-- Steven Spielberg's a good comparison, in a sense, as well. He made films that were very good, very commercial, very popular. And he also produced other people's films, had his own studio. And he was the most powerful, popular filmmaker in South Korea-- arguably, in all of Southeast Asia-- for most of the '60s and into the '70s.
形容申的最好方式——从某种意义上说，史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格是一个很好的比较。他制作的电影非常好，非常商业化，非常受欢迎。他还制作别人的电影，拥有自己的工作室。在60年代和70年代的大部分时间里，他是韩国——甚至可以说是整个东南亚——最有权势、最受欢迎的电影制作人。
And Shin-- 10 days prior to this, he was still in a prison camp-- got released. And for 10 days in a villa, they fattened them up, tried to restore him to health. He arrives at the party when it's already in full flow. And he walks inside, and as soon as he enters, there's applause.
在这次见面10天前，申还被关在劳改营里，刚被释放。在别墅里待了10天，他们把他养胖了，试图恢复他的健康。他在派对正进行得如火如荼时到达。他走了进去，他一入场，就响起了掌声。
What an insane thing. 10 days ago, you're in a prison camp. You walk in, and you're the life of the party. Everyone's applauding.
真是疯狂。10天前你还在劳改营。你走进去，你就是派对的焦点。每个人都在鼓掌。
Exactly. And in the pictures, his face still looks emaciated. You can tell he's just gone through something terrible. The suit doesn't fit.
没错。在照片里，他的脸看起来仍然消瘦。你能看出他刚刚经历了可怕的事情。西装也不合身。
Now Choi doesn't see Shin come in. She just hears people start applauding.
现在崔并没有看到申进来。她只听到人们开始鼓掌。
And Choi is sort of even unfazed by this. Anytime Kim does anything, people get up and applaud.
崔甚至对此无动于衷。每当金做任何事情，人们都会站起来鼓掌。
So she didn't know why people were applauding. She had no idea.
所以她不知道人们为什么鼓掌。她完全不知道。
Exactly. Until somebody says, why don't you look happy? Look who's here. And she turns around. And it's been five years. Shin's got the marks of having been tortured in a prison camp. She doesn't recognize him right away.
没错。直到有人说，你为什么看起来不高兴？看看谁来了。她转过身。已经五年了。申身上有在劳改营受过折磨的痕迹。她没有立刻认出他来。
And from that point on, Kim Jong-il was pulling them together. And they, sort of shell shocked, hugged one another, and then were then moved around, like blocking in a movie scene, by Kim Jong-il.
从那一刻起，金正日就把他们拉到了一起。他们有些震惊地拥抱在一起，然后被金正日像电影场景调度一样摆布。
What, like stand here, sit here?
什么，像站在这里，坐在那里？
Stand here. You stand next to me. Smile to the cameras. They were sort of the guests of honor.
站在这里。你站在我旁边。对着镜头微笑。他们算是贵宾。
Famous people don't get to pick their fans. Kim Jong-il was a superfan who was also, unfortunately, the son of the all-powerful leader of a totalitarian state. Shin and Choi had made their best movies together. Kim loved their movies, and he wanted them to be a couple, just like they were in their heyday. So he arranged it, Parent Trap style.
名人无法选择自己的粉丝。金正日是一个超级粉丝，同时不幸的是，他也是一个极权主义国家最高领导人的儿子。申和崔一起制作了他们最好的电影。金很喜欢他们的电影，他希望他们能像他们鼎盛时期那样成为一对。于是他安排了这一切，像《天生一对》那样。
He told them at the party that, guess what, he had a newly remodeled villa for them that they would be living in from now on-- together.
他在派对上告诉他们，猜猜怎么着，他为他们重新装修了一栋别墅，从现在起他们将住在那里——在一起。
Making a joke, I think he said something like, the newlyweds are going to want to be alone now.
开个玩笑，我想他说类似“新婚夫妇现在想独处了”之类的话。
What a weirdo.
真是个怪胎。
And had them taken to a car, and by all accounts, seemed extremely pleased and expected them to be equally so. And it's the moment right after that when they went back to the villa, closed the bathroom door, turned the faucets on--
然后让人把他们带上一辆车，无论从哪个角度看，他似乎都非常高兴，并且期待他们也同样高兴。就在那之后，他们回到别墅，关上浴室门，打开水龙头——
In order to talk privately. They turned the faucets on so they can whisper and actually have a private conversation.
为了私下交谈。他们打开水龙头，这样他们就可以耳语并进行真正的私下对话。
Exactly. And they just asked one another what had happened.
没错。他们只是问对方发生了什么。
The way she describes it is sort of a lovely moment, where she asks him, what happened to you? And he said, a lot. I'll tell you some other time. And he asks her, what happened to you? And she says, a lot. I'll tell you some other time.
她描述的方式是一个可爱的时刻，她问他，你发生了什么事？他说，发生了好多事。以后再告诉你。他问她，你发生了什么事？她说，发生了好多事。以后再告诉你。
And you know, Shin kind of gingerly, again, asked her, you know, you looked very smiley and happy. And I just-- have you been brainwashed? And she made a joke about how the director couldn't even recognize acting anymore. And both of them were finally able to be genuine with someone. And they spent the next several hours going through everything.
而且你知道，申有些谨慎地再次问她，你知道，你看起来非常开心和快乐。我只是——你被洗脑了吗？她开玩笑说，导演甚至认不出什么是演戏了。他们两个终于能够对某人坦诚相待。他们花了接下来的几个小时梳理了一切。
Shin and Choi made a long-term plan and a short-term plan. Long-term, they were going to escape. But they would wait till they could do it right so they wouldn't be caught. Their short-term plan involved a small tape recorder, which they were able to get, because one of the weird privileges of their captivity was that they were allowed to shop at a department store that sold things that were out of reach for most people in the country, like tape recorders.
申和崔制定了长期计划和短期计划。从长远来看，他们要逃跑。但他们会等到能正确实施的时候，这样就不会被抓住。他们的短期计划包括一个小录音机，他们得以弄到手，因为他们被囚禁的奇怪特权之一是，他们可以去一家百货商店购物，里面卖着大多数国内人买不到的东西，比如录音机。
Kim Jong-il had long- and short-term plans of his own for them. He told them that soon he would summon them to talk about his vision for their future. Then seven months went by.
金正日对他们也有长期和短期的计划。他告诉他们，不久他就会召见他们，谈谈他对他们未来的构想。然后七个月过去了。
And during those months, Shin and Choi spent hours nearly every week in Kim's huge film archive. He wanted Shin and Choi to see it and be impressed, and they were. Kim didn't just love their movies. He loved all movies.
在这几个月里，申和崔几乎每周都要在金庞大的电影资料馆里待上几个小时。他想让申和崔看到它并留下深刻印象，他们确实被震撼了。金不仅爱他们的电影，他爱所有的电影。
It was against the law for ordinary North Koreans to watch foreign films. But Kim had set up a massive bootlegging operation running in countries all over the world so he could build up his private collection with every movie ever made, or as close as he could get. The archive was three stories high and heavily guarded-- at least two screening rooms, all for Kim only, and now for Shin and Choi. Shin was bowled over by every detail.
普通朝鲜人看外国电影是违法的。但金在世界各地建立了大规模的盗版行动，这样他就可以用每一部拍过的电影来建立他的私人收藏，或者尽可能接近这个目标。资料馆有三层楼高，守卫森严——至少有两个放映厅，全部供金使用，现在也供申和崔使用。申被每一个细节震撼了。
The way the building itself was set up to run, and with admiration over how Kim had set up his own archive and how well everything was kept, geeking out over the air conditioning settings and how he was preserving the celluloid, and how everything was cataloged, then the staff, and then how large it was.
建筑本身的运作方式，以及对金如何建立自己的资料馆以及一切保存得如此完好的钦佩，对空调设置、他是如何保存胶片、一切是如何分类的、员工，以及它的规模之大感到惊叹。
How is it categorized? Was it by year, or by genre, or by director?
它是怎么分类的？是按年份、按类型还是按导演？
It went by country first. And then I think it went by year as they got them in. And then there's a lovely touch where the South Korean films are in a normal air conditioning room, and then the North Korean films were in the most lavish storage and screening room in the whole building.
首先是按国家。然后我想随着时间的推移，它们是按年份分类的。还有一个可爱的细节，韩国电影放在普通的空调房里，而朝鲜电影放在整个建筑中最豪华的存储和放映室里。
The films were dubbed into Korean after being painstakingly transcribed, sometimes by Americans. There was an American defector-- he was one of several, actually-- who'd been there since 1965. And one of his jobs was transcribing American films, but just by listening, because he wasn't allowed to watch them.
这些电影在经过艰苦的转录后被配成韩语，有时由美国人完成。有一名美国变节者——实际上他是其中之一——他从1965年就在那里了。他的工作之一是转录美国电影，但只是通过听，因为他不被允许看电影。
Yeah. And he wouldn't know that they were films because they gave him and the other American defectors the audio-- for some reason, they chopped up the film soundtracks into different bits in the wrong order so they wouldn't--
是啊。而且他不知道那是电影，因为他们给了他和另外几个美国变节者音频——由于某种原因，他们把电影原声带切成了不同的小段，顺序也是乱的，这样他们就不会——
Know what they were doing?
知道他们在做什么？
Exactly, or enjoy them. But he had this experience of transcribing and then suddenly realizing, wait, this is Mary Poppins.
没错，或者享受它们。但他有了转录的经历，然后突然意识到，等等，这是《欢乐满人间》。
Shin And Choi spent dozens and dozens of hours watching one movie after another in the screening rooms at the film archive and in their villa, which was also outfitted to show movies. They did that for months, until finally they got word-- Kim is ready to meet with you. They went, and they brought the tape recorder.
申和崔在电影资料馆的放映室和他们别墅里的放映室里看了几十又几十个小时的电影，别墅也配备了放映设施。他们这样做了几个月，直到最后接到消息——金准备见你们了。他们去了，并带上了录音机。
And the second they walked in, Choi had the tape recorder in her purse, and she flicked it on. And I think unexpectedly, Kim Jong-il just talked at them, mostly, for two hours.
他们一走进去，崔就把录音机放在包里，打开了开关。我想出乎意料的是，金正日大部分时间只是对着他们说了两个小时。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
[说韩语]
Kim Jong-il spoke very, very fast, and his mind went all over the place. And he had a very intimidating waiter slash bodyguard who kept walking in to refill drinks and empty ashtrays.
金正日说得非常非常快，他的思绪跳跃很大。他有一个非常令人生畏的服务员兼保镖，不断走进来续杯和清空烟灰缸。
Shin and Choi wanted to record Kim for two reasons. First, they knew they might not be able to escape. Maybe they would be killed, and their children and friends would just never know what had happened to them. A recording, if they could smuggle it out, would at least be proof of where they'd been.
申和崔想记录金正日有两个原因。首先，他们知道自己可能无法逃脱。也许他们会被杀，而他们的孩子和朋友永远不会知道他们发生了什么。录音，如果他们能走私出去，至少能证明他们去过哪里。
The second reason to record him was that they knew that Kim would insist they say publicly that they had come to North Korea on their own, voluntarily. Shin and Choi were hoping that, in their private conversation, Kim might admit to having had them kidnapped and brought to him. And he almost, almost did, by making a joke.
记录他的第二个原因是，他们知道金会坚持让他们公开宣称他们是自愿来到朝鲜的。申和崔希望在他们的私下谈话中，金可能会承认是绑架了他们并带到他身边。而他几乎，几乎做到了，通过开玩笑。
In the first couple of minutes of their conversation, Kim talked about how he'd brought Choi over first in order to entice Shin to North Korea. I say joke because Kim laughs as he says it, and then all three of them laugh.
在谈话的最初几分钟里，金谈到了他是如何先诱骗崔，以此将申引诱到朝鲜的。之所以说开玩笑，是因为金在说的时候笑了，然后他们三个人都笑了。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
[说韩语]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It's tyrant management 101. If he laughs, you laugh. The rest of what Kim said in that conversation-- well, he said a lot of things. But the main thing was, North Korean movies are bad, and I'm sick of it.
这是暴君管理101。如果他笑，你就笑。金在谈话中说的其余部分——好吧，他说了好多事情。但重点是，朝鲜电影很糟糕，我对此感到厌倦。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
[说韩语]
They were making the same film over and over again, and that they were too long and too boring, and like history lessons and too melodramatic. And he says there's too much crying. I didn't tell anybody to put in so much crying.
他们一遍又一遍地制作同一部电影，而且它们太长、太无聊，就像历史课，而且太煽情。他说哭戏太多了。我没有告诉任何人放这么多哭戏。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
[说韩语]
Kim Jong-il told Shin and Choi that he knew he was the only person in the country who could get away with saying what he was saying. And he told them not to repeat any of it. He said, when it comes to movies, we are in kindergarten, and other countries, like South Korea, are in college.
金正日告诉申和崔，他知道他是国内唯一一个可以说了这些话还能全身而退的人。他告诉他们不要重复任何这些话。他说，在电影方面，我们还在上幼儿园，而其他国家，比如韩国，已经在上大学了。
He said, if we don't catch up in the next 10 years, our movies are going to be the worst of the worst movies in the world. The problem, he said, just between us, is that people in North Korea had it too easy. They had things handed to them. They didn't have to hustle, like Shin and Choi did.
他说，如果我们未来10年赶不上，我们的电影将成为世界上最糟糕的电影。他说，我们之间私下说，问题在于朝鲜人民生活得太容易了。他们拥有唾手可得的东西。他们不必像申和崔那样拼搏。
There's a point in the tape where he tells them that-- and I think I'm going to paraphrase a bit. But he says, there's no incentive in socialism to do any better.
磁带里有一个地方，他告诉他们——我想我会稍微意译一下。但他说，社会主义没有激励机制让人做得更好。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
[说韩语]
He says, my screenwriters, they'll write something, they'll get their rations. The other guys make a film, they'll get their rations.
他说，我的编剧，他们会写东西，他们就能得到口粮。其他人拍部电影，他们也能得到口粮。
So they get paid no matter what, as long as they just turn out the work.
所以只要他们交出作品，无论好坏都能拿到报酬。
Exactly, and follow orders. And he seemed very conscious that he needs someone who pushes himself more than that, who's used to having to do more than that to earn his keep.
没错，还要服从命令。他似乎非常清楚，他需要一个比那更努力的人，一个习惯于付出更多才能维持生计的人。
Kim Jong-il never mentioned another possible reason why North Korea's movies were wooden and unambitious, like fear. He, Kim Jong-il, had written the book-- the only book in North Korea about the right way to make movies and think about movies. It's called On the Art of the Cinema. It's still in print.
金正日从没提到朝鲜电影死板、缺乏野心的另一个可能原因，比如恐惧。他，金正日，写过那本书——朝鲜唯一一本关于拍电影和思考电影正确方式的书。书名叫《电影艺术论》。它还在印刷。
Everyone involved in North Korea's film industry in the 1980s had to have been aware of the potential consequences of doing something as unpatriotic or insulting as trying to realize their own independent artistic vision. Without Kim's explicit blessing, and his father's, it was better to be crappy than sorry.
80年代参与朝鲜电影业的每个人都一定意识到了做出像试图实现自己独立艺术视野那样不爱国或侮辱行为的潜在后果。如果没有金明确的祝福，以及他父亲的祝福，坏一点总比后悔要好。
The conversation continued. Shin and Choi murmured that North Korea's citizens were fortunate to have a comrade leader who understood films so well. Kim Jong-il agreed. With his permission, the three of them got into critiquing specific films-- a North Korean one called The Star of Korea, and while they were at it, a Soviet film called Mother that had a dying scene they all agreed had been atrocious.
谈话继续进行。申和崔喃喃自语说，朝鲜公民很幸运有这样一位了解电影的同志领导。金正日表示赞同。经他许可，他们三人开始评论具体的电影——一部叫《朝鲜之星》的朝鲜电影，在评论的同时，还评论了一部叫《母亲》的苏联电影，他们都认为里面有一个临终场景惨不忍睹。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
[说韩语]
They were three movie lovers talking about what they loved. And Kim Jong-il's big plan for Shin and Choi was that he wanted them to make North Korean movies good so that they could compete with films coming out of the West and win awards and be shown in theaters all over the world. He wanted Choi to act in the movies and Shin to direct them. Shin could have his own film company, just like he used to have. Shin wanted to call the company Shin Film, a very bold request in the circumstances.
他们是三个电影爱好者在谈论他们所爱的东西。金正日对申和崔的大计划是他想让他们把朝鲜电影做好，这样他们就可以与西方电影竞争并赢得奖项，并在世界各地的影院放映。他想让崔去演电影，让申来执导。申可以拥有自己的电影公司，就像他过去拥有的那样。申想把公司命名为“申电影”，在这种情况下这是一个非常大胆的要求。
But yeah, nothing in North Korea had been called anything other than The Worker's Paradise this, or The Party this, or The Supreme Leader this, or Kim Il-sung University. So it was a big deal. But it's also very telling of Shin that, even in this surreal situation, his first instinct is, OK, OK, OK, OK, but can we give the company my name?
但确实，朝鲜没有任何东西叫这个，除了“工人天堂”什么什么，或者“党”什么什么，或者“最高领袖”什么什么，或者“金日成大学”。所以这是一个大事。但这也非常说明申的问题，即使在这种超现实的情况下，他的第一反应是，好，好，好，好，但我们能把公司命名为我的名字吗？
In film noir, someone is always using someone, and often, people are using each other. And we don't find out until the end who gets away with what. Shin and Choi knew that their only chance of escape would be to convince Kim Jong-il to let them film and work in the West. Kim Jong-il knew that if he wanted good movies, he had to give Shin and Choi enough freedom to create them. So all three of them wanted to make great movies. But--
在黑色电影中，总有人在利用别人，通常，人们在互相利用。直到最后我们才知道谁逃脱了惩罚。申和崔知道他们唯一的逃跑机会就是说服金正日让他们在西方拍摄和工作。金正日知道，如果他想要好电影，他就必须给申和崔足够的自由去创作。所以他们三个人都想制作伟大的电影。但是——
Same bed, different dreams. Kim Jong-il wanted the films for his own purposes, and they needed the films to get away from him. And it's almost like his ambition of making films that the world will respect completely overtook any sense of logic.
同床异梦。金正日想要这些电影是为了他自己的目的，而他们需要这些电影来逃离他。这几乎就像他想制作让世界尊重的电影的野心完全压倒了任何逻辑感。
So the first film Shin and Choi shot had sequences that they shot in Eastern Europe, standing in for the Hague. And they showed Kim Jong-il the film. He said, this is fantastic. It's like a European film. It's the best thing we've ever made. Allowed them to start showing it. And it never crossed his mind that they had done exactly what he'd forbidden his own filmmakers to do forever for a reason.
所以申和崔拍的第一部电影里有一些他们在东欧拍摄的场景，用来代替海牙。他们给金正日看了这部电影。他说，这太棒了。就像一部欧洲电影。这是我们制作过的最好的东西。允许他们开始放映它。他从未想过他们做了他一直禁止自己的电影制作人做的事情，而且是有原因的。
They'd been forbidden to show the world outside North Korea.
他们被禁止展示朝鲜以外的世界。
They showed people things that they hadn't been able to see almost in a lifetime, for some people in North Korea, by 1983, 1984. And the second that film started playing in cinemas in North Korea, the North Korean audiences didn't take in, necessarily, the higher production values.
他们向人们展示了他们几乎一生都没能看到的东西，对一些朝鲜人来说，到1983、1984年的时候。在那部电影开始在朝鲜电影院放映的那一刻，朝鲜观众不一定是在吸收更高的制作价值。
All they could talk about was that first 10, 15 minutes shot on the streets of Prague where-- OK, wait. The buildings look amazing. People are walking into businesses. They're all dressed differently. There's cars. What?
他们谈论的都是那前10、15分钟在布拉格街道上拍摄的内容，那里——好吧，等等。这些建筑看起来太棒了。人们走进商店。他们穿的衣服都不一样。有汽车。什么？
That's what really had an impact. Because up until then, they had been told, you are the luckiest people in the world. The Worker's Paradise is the only place in the world where people have peace and freedom. And suddenly they saw that that wasn't true.
那才是真正产生影响的地方。因为在此之前，他们被告知，你们是世界上最幸运的人。“工人天堂”是世界上唯一人们拥有和平与自由的地方。突然间他们看到那不是真的。
How do you know that that's what people thought?
你怎么知道人们是这么想的？
I was lucky enough to meet and speak to people who'd escaped from North Korea, who were of varying ages at the time that they were able to watch these films. And there's another German researcher in Japan now called Johannes Schonherr, who's done quite a lot of talking to defectors about the same thing. And it's one of the things that's fascinating is that Shin and Choi's films had a huge impact straightaway. I mean, there would have been people in their late 30s who'd never seen anything of the outside world that hadn't been filtered.
我很幸运能见到并采访那些从朝鲜逃出来的人，他们在能够看这些电影时年龄各异。现在在日本还有另一位德国研究员叫约翰内斯·肖恩赫尔，他曾与变节者就同样的事情进行了相当多的交谈。迷人的地方之一是申和崔的电影立即产生了巨大的影响。我的意思是，会有30多岁的人从未看过任何未经过滤的外部世界的东西。
But it wasn't just that people suddenly were able to see footage of the outside world. But Shin and Choi made a film called Love, Love, My Love, which was literally the first love story in North Korean culture post 1945 that wasn't about love of the leader or love of the party. It was literally the first time people were able to go to the cinema and see something that was about two people falling in love. And it was the first time teenagers had pictures on their wall of a matinee idol, of anybody other than the leaders.
但这不仅是人们突然能够看到外部世界的镜头。而是申和崔制作了一部名为《爱情，爱情，我的爱情》的电影，这是朝鲜1945年后真正意义上的第一部不是关于爱领袖或爱党的爱情故事。这是人们第一次能够走进电影院看到关于两个坠入爱河的人的东西。这也是青少年第一次在墙上贴上偶像的海报，而不是领导人的照片。
Shin directed seven films for Kim Jong-il. And then in March 1986, he and Choi went to a hotel in Vienna for some film business, managed to grab a separate taxi from their North Korean minders, sped to the US Embassy, and ran in. They were debriefed by the CIA, and later by South Korean intelligence. And they were interviewed by The Washington Post and other media outlets.
申为金正日执导了七部电影。然后在1986年3月，他和崔去维也纳的一家酒店处理一些电影业务，设法从他们的朝鲜随从那里拦了一辆单独的出租车，疾驰到美国大使馆，跑了进去。他们受到了中央情报局的审查，后来又接受了韩国情报部门的采访。他们还接受了《华盛顿邮报》和其他媒体机构的采访。
And stories about North Korea are always hard to fact check. For parts of Shin and Choi's story, their recollections, their interpretations are all there is. But the movies exist. The recording of Kim exists.
关于朝鲜的故事总是很难核实。对于申和崔故事的部分内容，他们的回忆、他们的解读就是全部。但电影存在。金的录音存在。
Kim Jong-il had told Shin and Choi in the recording that when people asked them why they were in North Korea, they should say, freedom, for true artistic freedom. For Shin, there was some bitter truth to that, because South Korea, at the time Shin and Choi were kidnapped, had been a military dictatorship with very heavy-handed censors.
金正日在录音中告诉申和崔，当人们问他们为什么在朝鲜时，他们应该说是为了自由，为了真正的艺术自由。对于申来说，这有一些苦涩的真理，因为在申和崔被绑架时，韩国是一个军事独裁政权，有非常严厉的审查制度。
Shin's studio had been shut down by the South Korean government in 1975. His career was in ruins. In North Korea, Shin got to make films again. He wrote unabashedly in his autobiography how much he had loved making movies there.
申的工作室在1975年被韩国政府关闭。他的职业生涯毁了。在朝鲜，申又能拍电影了。他在自传中毫无顾忌地写道，他有多喜欢在那里拍电影。
Shin always spoke of North Korea as the place he associated film freedom with and creative freedom with, because he could ask for anything and get it. In one episode, he asked for a model train to blow up for a scene. And he was given a real train packed with explosives on rails to blow up if he wanted to.
申总是提到朝鲜是他将电影自由和创作自由联系在一起的地方，因为他可以要求任何东西并得到它。有一次，他要求一辆模型火车在一个场景中被炸掉。他得到了一辆装满炸药的真火车，如果他愿意就可以炸掉。
And if he asked for a wind machine, he was sent helicopters. And if he wanted fake snow, everybody was flown to a mountain. There was no expense spared.
如果他要求风力机，他就会被派来直升机。如果他想要假雪，每个人都会被飞往一座山。不惜一切代价。
Kim Jong-il felt like the larger-than-life film producer that you hear about. And he didn't have the downside that a film producer usually has, because a film producer usually has to say no every now and then. We don't have enough money. We don't have enough time.
金正日感觉就像你听说过的那种超乎寻常的电影制片人。他没有电影制片人通常会有的缺点，因为电影制片人通常不得不时不时地说不。我们没有足够的钱。我们没有足够的时间。
Shin and Choi had remarried in North Korea at Kim Jong-il's suggestion. And it ended up being a real marriage. They were together until Shin died in 2006. They seemed to have been each other's big love in life, besides movies. Although Shin loved movies more than Choi did-- maybe a lot more.
申和崔在金正日的建议下在朝鲜再婚了。这最终成为了一段真正的婚姻。他们一直在一起，直到申在2006年去世。除了电影之外，他们似乎是彼此生命中的真爱。虽然申比崔更爱电影——也许爱得多得多。
In their shared memoir of their time in North Korea, it goes from his voice to her voice, back and forth. And the second they start making films, her voice kind of disappears entirely, and it's all his from then on. And it's about escaping, but in equal measure, it's about making the films, almost as if he's writing a memoir of his time in Hollywood or something.
在他们关于朝鲜时光的共同回忆录中，它在两人的声音之间来回切换。当他们开始拍电影的那一刻，她的声音就彻底消失了，从那时起全都是他的声音。这关于逃跑，但同样也关于拍电影，几乎就像他是在写他在好莱坞时光的回忆录。
Choi's 88 years old, living in South Korea. When Paul was researching his book, he interviewed her for it. And he asked her about Shin and the movies they made in North Korea.
崔88岁了，住在韩国。保罗在研究他的书时采访了她。他问她关于申以及他们在朝鲜拍摄的电影。
And when I met her and spoke to her, you could sense the impatience that if she had been able to get out of there three years earlier and not made any of films, she would've been very happy to do so.
当我见到她并与她交谈时，你能感觉到那种不耐烦，如果她能早三年从那里出来，没有拍任何电影，她会非常乐意。
And him, not so much.
而他，并不是那么乐意。
Even great love can't protect you from the other person wanting what they want.
即使是伟大的爱情也无法保护你不受对方想要他们想要的东西的影响。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our show. Paul Fischer's book about all this is called A Kim Jong-il Production. We first broadcast this story in 2015. Choi Eun-Hee has died since then.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制片人之一。保罗·费舍尔关于这一切的书叫《金正日作品》。我们第一次在2015年广播了这个故事。崔银姬此后去世了。
Coming up, people sharing beds-- actual beds-- with very different dreams. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，人们共享床铺——真正的床铺——但有着截然不同的梦想。那将在一分钟后从芝加哥公共广播电台播出，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, "Same Bed, Different Dreams," we have stories of people who are bound closely together. They are stuck with each other, but with very different hopes and goals. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "Smell You Later."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目“同床异梦”中，我们有关于那些被紧密联系在一起的人的故事。他们被困在一起，但怀有截然不同的希望和目标。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“回头再闻”。
There are all kinds of work situations where people very literally share an actual bed so they can do their jobs. These are people who share a bed that they are not ever in at the same time. This happens in lots of places. It has different names-- shift beds, hot sheeting, hot bedding.
各种工作情况下，人们确实共享一张实际的床，以便他们可以完成工作。这些人共享一张他们从不在同一时间使用的床。这种情况在很多地方发生。它有不同的名字——轮班床、热床铺、热铺。
Flight attendants do this. There are apartments with bunk beds that they use when they happen to be in that city. Guys who work on oil rigs and oil fields do it, too.
空乘人员就这样。有一些公寓里有双层床，当他们碰巧在那个城市时就会使用它们。在石油钻井平台和油田工作的人也这样做。
We have to swap out sheets every time that we're going to-- every time that we're going to go to our ship. Swap out your sheets, and put my sheets.
每次我们去……每次我们去我们的船时，都得换床单。换下你的床单，铺上我的床单。
This guy works in Carlsbad, New Mexico. When he and a friend first moved there two years ago to do fracking, to save money, they rented this small RV, just like 15 feet long, one bed in it. He worked nights. His friend worked days. They had a rule to always shower before getting in the bed.
这家伙在新墨西哥州的卡尔斯巴德工作。当他和朋友两年前第一次搬到那里进行水力压裂时，为了省钱，他们租了这辆只有15英尺长的小房车，里面只有一张床。他上夜班。他朋友上日班。他们有一个规定，上床前一定要洗澡。
The sheets-- my friend's always been real picky on that. He always had a color blue. I always liked red sheets, something bright. So every time that I'd leave, he always had my red sheets on. Every time that I'd leave, I'd always put his blue sheets on.
床单——我朋友在这方面一直很挑剔。他总是用蓝色。我一直喜欢红色的床单，颜色鲜艳的那种。所以每次我离开时，他总是铺着我的红色床单。每次我离开时，我总是铺上他的蓝色床单。
And plus, we never got the same shoes, because we never wanted to be mixed up and stuff. That'd be pretty messed up, smelling him, and he'd be smelling me and stuff.
而且，我们从不穿一样的鞋子，因为我们从不想弄混之类的。那样会很糟糕，闻着他，他也会闻着我什么的。
Migrant workers also have these shift beds in some places at farms around the country. In New York, the main agriculture product is milk. There are over 4,000 dairy farms in the state. And lots of them operate 24/7, so shift beds are common.
农民工在全国各地的农场里也有这些轮班床。在纽约，主要的农产品是牛奶。该州有超过4,000个奶牛场。它们很多都是24/7运作的，所以轮班床很常见。
Stephanie Foo went see the shift beds at one of those farms.
斯蒂芬妮·富去看了其中一个农场的轮班床。
I didn't see any cows on the farm. And more surprising, I didn't smell them. Instead, there were just sweet smelling bales of hay in a field with three mobile homes on it. Mexican music was blasting out of the closest one.
我在农场里没看到任何奶牛。更令人惊讶的是，我没闻到它们的气味。取而代之的是，田野里只有散发着甜味的干草捆，上面有三间移动房屋。最近的一间正播放着震耳欲聋的墨西哥音乐。
My interpreter, Antonia, and I knock on the door. And as soon as we step inside, the stench of manure is overpowering from a few mud-caked boots in the corner. It's a two-bedroom trailer with holes in the floor and black mold growing in the cabinets, and clutter everywhere-- roaches, and jars of Nescafe, and sugar, and cans of beans, Coronas.
我的翻译安东尼娅和我敲了门。我们一进去，角落里几双沾满泥巴的靴子散发出令人窒息的粪便恶臭。这是一个两居室的拖车，地板上有洞，橱柜里长着黑霉，到处都是杂物——蟑螂、雀巢咖啡罐、糖、罐装豆子、科罗娜啤酒。
It's 7:00 PM, and we're there during the shift change. There are four or five guys milling around, all Mexican, all undocumented. Some are just getting home, and others, like this one guy, Jose, are just waking up for work. Jose's shy, but he smiles a lot. He shows Antonio and me where he sleeps.
现在是晚上7点，我们是在轮班交接期间在那里。有四五个人在走动，都是墨西哥人，都是无证件者。有些人刚下班回家，其他人，像这个叫何塞的家伙，刚醒来准备上班。何塞很害羞，但他经常笑。他带着安东尼奥和我去他睡觉的地方。
Oh, wow. There's a bed in the bathroom.
哦，哇。浴室里有一张床。
Jose lifts up the bed's mattress and a wooden blanket underneath, knocking over a jar of change. And--
何塞掀起床垫和下面的一条木毯子，打翻了一个硬币罐。然后——
Oh. Are you in the bathtub?
哦。你在浴缸里吗？
Sí. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
是的。[说西班牙语]
He joked that if he wanted to take a bath, he could just lift up his bed and get in. His bed is a wooden plank placed over the tub. There are a couple of pillows shoved over the faucet so that the knobs don't turn and flood the tub while he's sleeping. It's happened before.
他开玩笑说，如果他想洗澡，他可以掀起他的床进去。他的床是一块横在浴缸上的木板。水龙头上塞着几个枕头，这样旋钮就不会转动并淹没浴缸，当他睡觉时。这以前发生过。
Including the bathtub bed, there are a total of seven beds in the two-bedroom mobile home. Sometimes up to 13 people live here and share the seven beds, sleeping in shifts.
包括浴缸床在内，这间两居室的移动房屋里总共有七张床。有时多达13个人住在这里，共享这七张床，轮班睡觉。
Jose explained how it works. No, there are no alarm clocks. No need for them. When you get off work, you find someone who has an opposite shift from you, and you wake them up so you can take their bed.
何塞解释了它是如何工作的。不，没有闹钟。不需要它们。当你下班时，你找一个和你轮班时间相反的人，叫醒他们，这样你就可以占用他们的床。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Jose says, OK, I get here at 4:00 AM, and my friend is sleeping. And I tap him on his blanket, and it goes like this.
何塞说，好吧，我凌晨4点到这里，我朋友在睡觉。我拍拍他的毯子，它是这样的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Who is it?
是谁？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Me, Jose.
是我，何塞。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It's 5:00. It's 5:00. It's 5:00. And they try to go back to sleep. Let me sleep.
是5点了。5点了。5点了。他们试图继续睡。让我睡吧。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And I say, it's 5:00. It's 5:00. It's 5:00. And they say, OK, OK. It's 5:00.
我说，是5点了。5点了。5点了。他们说，好吧，好吧。5点了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Then I get ready for bed. He wakes up and says, OK, see you later. I'll wake you later.
然后我准备睡觉。他醒来说，好吧，回头见。我待会儿叫你。
And does it feel strange and intimate? Or did it at first, when you had to share a bed with somebody?
那感觉奇怪和亲密吗？或者刚开始必须和别人共用一张床时是这样吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Jose says, yes, of course, yeah. You're used to coming to work. And suddenly, someone else comes and sleeps in your bed, in your blankets. You should see. It's weird. You flip your pillow over each time.
何塞说，是的，当然，是的。你习惯了上班。突然，别人进来睡在你的床上，在你的毯子里。你应该看看。这很奇怪。你每次都要把枕头翻过来。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
But you get used to it, to everyone's smells. We become friends. You know that if he showers, it's fine. But if not, I understand.
但你习惯了，习惯了每个人的气味。我们成了朋友。你知道如果他洗澡了，就没问题。但如果没有，我理解。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Because sometimes you don't get back until 7:00 or 6:00, and there's no time to shower. I'm understanding of that, and he should be too. It's fine. I mean, you get used to it, really.
因为有时你到7点或6点才回来，没有时间洗澡。我理解这一点，他也应该理解。没关系。我的意思是，你真的习惯了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
That's what everyone kept telling me, you get used to it-- to the hours, to the work, to everyone else rummaging around in your space. You get used to it.
每个人都一直这样告诉我，你习惯了——习惯了时间，习惯了工作，习惯了每个人在你的空间里翻来翻去。你习惯了。
Jose and Antonio works seven days a week, 16 hours three days a week, eight hours the other four, no overtime. I talked to a guy who's worked closely with many farms across the state, and he described the pay and living conditions at the farm we were at as, quote, "slightly below average."
何塞和安东尼奥每周工作七天，三天每天16小时，其他四天每天8小时，没有加班费。我和一个在州内许多农场紧密合作的人交谈过，他描述我们所在的农场的工资和生活条件为，引用，“略低于平均水平”。
Jose says it's not that bad. He says other farms he's lived at have been worse. At one, the roof leaked onto the beds, and it was so crowded that he'd try to sleep standing up.
何塞说没那么糟。他说他住过的其他农场更糟。在一个农场，屋顶漏水到床上，而且太拥挤了，他试着站着睡觉。
At another, he couldn't sleep because he was afraid that a drunk, violent roommate would beat him up in the middle of the night. Here, they get along. If someone wants to bring his girlfriend over, the rest of them all cram into the other bedroom, even sleep together in one bed so that guy can have a room to himself.
在另一个农场，他睡不着觉，因为他害怕喝醉的、暴力的室友会在半夜打他。在这里，他们相处得很好。如果有人想带女朋友过来，其他人都会挤到另一个卧室，甚至睡在同一张床上，这样那个人就可以拥有一个属于自己的房间。
But mostly, they're not too concerned about privacy. As I squeezed past piles of other people's toiletries and clothes and sheets and condom wrappers all over the floor, I was reminded of what a luxury it is to ever feel like you have a space that's all yours. Here, at any given moment, somebody might be in the next room bumping the Black Eyed Peas off YouTube and singing at the top of their lungs.
但大部分时间，他们并不太关心隐私。当我挤过地上一堆堆别人的洗漱用品、衣服、床单和安全套包装袋时，我被提醒，感到拥有一个完全属于自己的空间是一种多么奢侈的事情。在这里，在任何时刻，隔壁房间可能有人正从YouTube上播放黑眼豆豆的歌，并大声歌唱。
(SINGING) Here we go. Here we go. We gonna rock, rock, rock, rock. Easy come. Easy go.
（歌唱）我们要走了。我们要走了。我们要摇滚，摇滚，摇滚，摇滚。来得容易。去得也快。
This is a guy named Antonio singing. He got really excited at this part because he knew the days of the week in English.
这是一个叫安东尼奥的人在唱歌。他在这一部分非常兴奋，因为他知道英语里的星期几。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
(SINGING) Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, and Thursday, Friday--
（歌唱）星期一，星期二，星期三，星期四，星期五——
Well, most of the days.
好吧，大部分日子。
All this is bearable because it's temporary. They do this a few years, then move home. And Antonio tells me he makes more in one day here than he would in a whole week in Mexico, and sends it all back. One man says he actually owns his own farm in Mexico, with his own workers, and that he's working here to be able to expand it.
这一切都是可以忍受的，因为它是暂时的。他们这样做几年，然后回家。安东尼奥告诉我，他在这里一天赚的钱比他在墨西哥一周赚的还要多，而且全部寄回去。一个人说他实际上在墨西哥拥有自己的农场，有自己的工人，他在这里工作是为了能够扩大它。
Many guys have built businesses. One is putting two kids through college. Jose says he bought a big house for his girlfriend in Mexico. Another man puts it best. He says, every head is its own world. I come for my dreams, and he comes for his.
许多人建立了企业。一个人供两个孩子上大学。何塞说他为他在墨西哥的女朋友买了一栋大房子。另一个人说得最好。他说，每个头脑都是它自己的世界。我为了我的梦想而来，他为了他的梦想而来。
One of the things Antonio-- the guy who was singing-- dreams about is his bed, his future bed. He can picture exactly what his bedroom in Mexico will look like once he's finished building it.
安东尼奥——那个唱歌的人——梦想的事情之一是他的床，他未来的床。他能准确地想象出一旦他建好后，他在墨西哥的卧室会是什么样子。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
With a sturdy red floor. That's a color I like. The bedrooms each have a bathroom.
带着坚固的红色地板。那是种我喜欢的颜色。卧室里都有浴室。
[SPEAKING SPANISH] with internet, [SPEAKING SPANISH], Netflix.
[说西班牙语] 有互联网，[说西班牙语]，Netflix。
What size bed do you want? And is it firm, or is it soft?
你想要多大的床？它是硬的还是软的？
King size, no? [SPEAKING SPANISH]
特大号的，不吗？[说西班牙语]
King-sized waterbed. It's the best, no?
特大号水床。那是最好的，不吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
That's why we're here. Antonio cracks another Corona. It's getting late for him. He has to get up in six hours for his shift.
这就是我们在这里的原因。安东尼奥打开另一瓶科罗娜啤酒。对他来说时间不早了。他还有六个小时就要起床去换班了。
I shake his hand, but before I go, I notice that I don't smell the manure anymore. I haven't smelled in a while, actually. The air seems cold and fresh. They're right. You really can get used to the smell.
我握了握他的手，但在我离开之前，我注意到我再也闻不到粪便的气味了。实际上，我好一会儿没闻到了。空气似乎既寒冷又清新。他们是对的。你真的可以习惯这种气味。
Stephanie Foo-- she's currently working on a memoir about healing from complex PTSD.
斯蒂芬妮·富——她目前正在写一本关于从复杂创伤后应激障碍中康复的回忆录。
Her story was first broadcast in 2015. When it aired, somebody who knew the managers of the farm apparently heard Stephanie's story on the radio and then talked to the managers like, hey, that sounds like your place. And then the manager apparently talked to the workers. And at some point, the Mexican consulate sent a guy in a car to help straighten this out. And soon enough-- chop, chop-- new trailer. Nobody shares a bed. Nobody sleeps in the bathtub anymore.
她的故事第一次在2015年广播。当它播出时，一个认识农场经理的人显然在收音机里听到了斯蒂芬妮的故事，然后跟经理说，嘿，那听起来像是你们的地方。然后经理显然跟工人们谈了谈。在某个时候，墨西哥领事馆派了一个人开车来帮忙整顿这件事。很快——利索地——新拖车。没人共用一张床。没人再睡在浴缸里了。
Act Three, "The Haunted Becomes The Haunter." This next story is about two women who aren't sleeping in the same bed. They're kind of inhabiting the same body, in a way, with very different dreams. Miki Meek tells what happened.
第三幕，“鬼魂变成了闹鬼者”。下一个故事是关于两个没有睡在同一张床上的女人的。从某种意义上说，她们占据着同一个身体，但怀有截然不同的梦想。米基·米克讲述了发生的事情。
Jessamyn Lovell didn't know she had a secret doppelganger until she got a phone call. Jessamyn is a photographer and teaches photography at the University of New Mexico in Albuquerque. And one morning, she was heading out the door for work.
杰萨敏·洛弗尔不知道她有一个秘密替身，直到她接到一个电话。杰萨敏是一位摄影师，在阿尔伯克基的新墨西哥大学教授摄影。那天早上，她正准备出门去上班。
And I get this call, and he identified himself as Inspector Crudo from the San Francisco Police Department Financial Crimes Unit. And he immediately asked me, do you know a woman named Erin Colleen Hart? And I said, no, and why?
我接到了这个电话，他自称是来自旧金山警察局金融犯罪部门的克鲁多探长。他立即问我，你认识一个叫艾琳·科琳·哈特的人吗？我说，不认识，为什么？
And he said, well, did you ever give her your identification, your New Mexico State driver's license, or any other identification? And I said, no, no. I don't know her. And, what is this about? And I immediately thought of my wallet being stolen, a year and a half prior, at this gallery in San Francisco.
他说，嗯，你有没有给过她你的证件、你的新墨西哥州驾照或任何其他证件？我说，不，没有。我不认识她。这到底是怎么回事？我立刻想到我的钱包在一年半前在旧金山的一家画廊被偷了。
She never got it back, and assumed it was gone for good. But now this police inspector was telling her that a woman named Erin Hart had just been busted using Jessamyn driver's license, trying to check into a San Francisco hotel.
她再也没拿回来，以为它永远丢了。但现在这位警察探长告诉她，一个叫艾琳·哈特的女人刚刚因为试图使用杰萨敏的驾照登记入住旧金山的一家酒店而被抓。
Then he said, look, I'll send you a police report. She's in police custody right now.
然后他说，听着，我会寄给你一份警方报告。她现在被警方拘留了。
And she was in police custody because she had been trying to use your ID?
她被警方拘留是因为她试图使用你的证件？
Yeah, exactly. I don't know. I just kind of thought, that sucks that that happened. And that's that, and whatever.
对，没错。我不知道。我只是觉得，发生这种事真倒霉。就是这样，随便吧。
But then about a week after that, it became clear that Jessamyn's license had been used at more places than just the hotel. A collections agency demanded payment from Jessamyn for $500 worth of goods from a Whole Foods store. Unpaid parking tickets and toll evasions also started showing up in her mailbox. And then the rental car company, Hertz, began hounding her for thousands of dollars in charges.
但在那之后大约一周，很明显杰萨敏的驾照不仅仅在酒店被使用过。一家收债机构要求杰萨敏支付500美元的全食超市商品费用。未付的停车罚单和逃费记录也开始出现在她的信箱里。然后租车公司赫兹开始为数千美元的费用而纠缠她。
I figured out and sort of added it up, and it was all, like, three different cars that she had rented. So one she just returned. Another one she had clearly damaged. And another one, the boot had been put on it, and there were tickets and whatever. I knew I had not rented these cars, and yet they would not believe me. They would not believe me.
我算了一下，总共加起来，她租了三辆不同的车。其中一辆她刚归还。另一辆她显然损坏了。第三辆，上面被锁了，还有罚单之类的。我知道我没有租过这些车，但他们不相信我。他们不相信我。
She was spending all her time on the phone and email, trying to tell them and other places that she'd been a victim of identity theft. And then Jessamyn got a summons to appear in court from Alameda County Court in Oakland. The charge against her was petty theft.
她把所有时间都花在电话和电子邮件上，试图告诉他们和其他地方她是身份盗窃的受害者。然后杰萨敏收到了来自奥克兰阿拉米达县法院的出庭传票。对她的指控是轻微盗窃。
So I was really freaked out. This must be connected to her, this woman, Erin Hart.
所以我真的很害怕。这一定和她有关，那个女人，艾琳·哈特。
So she bought a plane ticket on a credit card and flew to Oakland. Once Jessamyn got there, she sat around in a courtroom all morning, waiting to be called up.
所以她用信用卡买了张机票飞往奥克兰。杰萨敏到那里后，在法庭上坐了一整个上午，等待被传唤。
I was getting more and more ramped up. Felt like a lot of people were getting taken away.
我越来越紧张了。感觉好像很多人被带走了。
Until she was finally the last person in the room.
直到她终于成了房间里最后一个人。
And then the judge asked me, are you the one that sent this big pile of papers in to me? And I was like, yes, those are all the documents. She's like, OK, I'm going to look through them really quickly here.
然后法官问我，是你把这一大堆文件寄给我的吗？我说，是的，那些全是文件。她说，好吧，我在这里快速浏览一下。
Because what was in there again?
因为里面又有什么？
All of the Hertz stuff, and then the police report-- just to show, believe me, this isn't the only thing.
所有赫兹的东西，还有警方报告——只是为了展示，相信我，这不仅仅是这一件事。
Yeah.
对。
There's all this other stuff going on.
还有所有这些其他事情在发生。
The judge dismissed the case but told Jessamyn she should get the charge expunged so it wouldn't appear in background checks, which was going to be a whole other hassle. She walked out of the courtroom, and she was still completely worked up.
法官驳回了此案，但告诉杰萨敏她应该将指控消除，这样它就不会出现在背景调查中，这将是另一个麻烦。她走出法庭，仍然完全情绪激动。
How much was this going to cost her? Who was this woman? And what else had she done posing as Jessamyn?
这会花她多少钱？那个女人是谁？她还有什么打着杰萨敏旗号做过的事情？
I thought immediately, I'm going to get to the bottom of this. I'm going to figure this out. I want to know what it was she did. I want to know how she got my ID. I wanted to find her. I wanted to find her.
我立刻想，我一定要查个水落石出。我一定要弄清楚这一点。我想知道她做了什么。我想知道她是怎么拿到我的证件的。我想找到她。我想找到她。
This is where Jessamyn's story changes from a garden variety identity theft case to something stranger. She had a photocopy of Erin Hart's driver's license in the file she took to court. So she pulled it out and looked at the home address listed on it.
这就是杰萨敏的故事从普通的身份盗窃案变成更奇怪的事情的地方。在带去法庭的档案里，她有一张艾琳·哈特驾照的复印件。所以她把它拿出来，看了看上面列出的家庭住址。
I had enough drive, just adrenaline, that I was like, I'm going there, just like, I'm doing this thing.
我有足够的动力，仅仅是肾上腺素，我觉得，我要去那里，就像，我正在做这件事。
And what was the thing that you were thinking you were going to do?
那你想到要做的事情是什么？
I don't know. I mean, I seriously-- I wish I could tell you I had a plan and I had something I was going to say, and I just didn't. And I remember thinking, well, I want to park close enough that I can run and get into my car if I have to. Not even kidding, I really did think that.
我不知道。我的意思是，我真的很——我希望我能告诉你我有一个计划，我有一些要说的话，但我根本没有。我记得我想，嗯，我想停得足够近，如果必须的话，我可以跑去上车。真的不是开玩笑，我真的那么想。
It was this huge, huge, huge, huge, huge apartment building. And I got in. Someone went in, and I just snuck in after them. I'm going in. I know her apartment number. I'm going to go in.
这是一个巨大巨大巨大巨大巨大巨大巨大巨大巨大巨大巨大巨大的公寓楼。我进去了。有人进去了，我就尾随他们溜了进去。我进去了。我知道她的公寓号。我要进去。
And so I'm walking through the halls, and I'd found the apartment. I just went up to it and knocked on it. And no one answered the door. And then I'm relieved. And I'm like, OK, well, I have to leave. And then I photographed the door, maybe one of the most boring pictures ever taken in my life.
所以我走在走廊里，找到了那个公寓。我径直走过去敲了敲门。没有人开门。然后我松了口气。我说，好吧，我得离开了。然后我拍了那扇门的照，可能是我一生中拍过的最无聊的照片之一。
Wait, why? Like, why take a picture?
等等，为什么？为什么要拍照？
I almost wanted just to have the evidence for myself that, like, you went there. You did this. Almost like-- I mean, I don't want to overstate it, but like a tourist's documents. I kind of felt like I needed to have this pin dropped there. I know it sounds crazy in hindsight. It kind of does sound a little weird in hindsight.
我几乎只想为自己保留证据，证明，你去了那里。你做了这件事。几乎就像——我的意思是，我不想夸大它，但这就像游客的文件。我觉得我需要把那根针扔在那里。我知道事后看来这听起来很疯狂。事后看来确实听起来有点奇怪。
Jessamyn also went to the Hertz counter in San Francisco, where three cars were rented in her name, and the Whole Foods in Berkeley, where she had a $500 debt, and Hotel Vitale. That's where Erin Hart got arrested trying to check in with her license. Walking in, Jessamyn saw that it was the type of hotel she'd never be able to stay at.
杰萨敏还去了旧金山的赫兹柜台，在那里有人用她的名字租了三辆车，还有伯克利的全食超市，她在那里欠了500美元债务，以及维塔利酒店。那就是艾琳·哈特试图用她的证件登记入住时被捕的地方。杰萨敏走进去，看到那是那种她永远住不起的酒店。
And I was not prepared for how fancy this place was going to be. Right away, coming in the door, they had wine, or they had tea. And the hotel staff immediately asked me if they could help me.
我没准备好这个地方会这么豪华。一进门，他们就提供红酒，或者茶。酒店员工立刻问我是否需要帮助。
And as soon as I said this woman had tried to check in here with my ID, the guy knew. And actually, he said that usually when this happens-- and I was like, oh, this happens a lot? And he's like, yes. And when that happens, we ask them to leave, and they leave. And he said, this woman didn't leave.
我一说这个女人曾试图用我的证件在这里登记入住，那家伙就知道了。实际上，他说通常发生这种情况时——我说，哦，这种情况经常发生吗？他说，是的。当发生这种情况时，我们请他们离开，他们就离开了。他说，这个女人没有离开。
The manager knew Erin was a fraud because she got Jessamyn's name wrong when she checked in. She had a beautifully groomed Persian cat with her, and was standing in the lobby insisting that the license was hers. That's when the manager decided to call the police.
经理知道艾琳是个骗子，因为她登记时把杰萨敏的名字搞错了。她带着一只梳理得非常漂亮的波斯猫，站在大堂里坚持说驾照是她的。那时候经理决定报警。
So they arrested her, and they took her away. And the cat was just left there with her stuff. And they were like, well, I guess we'll have to call animal humane. And then she came a couple days later-- she was released-- and asked for her cat at the hotel.
所以他们逮捕了她，把她带走了。猫就和她的东西一起留在那儿了。他们说，嗯，我猜我们得叫动物保护中心。然后她几天后回来了——她被释放了——在酒店里找她的猫。
And they said, well, I'm sorry. We sent her to-- and she was really upset that the cat wasn't there. That definitely was the first moment where I had any kind of sympathy for her. And they gave her the number for animal humane, and then she left. Now when I went to animal humane--
他们说，嗯，抱歉。我们把它送到——她对猫不在那里感到非常难过。那绝对是我对她产生任何同情心的第一个时刻。他们给了她动物保护中心的电话号码，然后她就离开了。当我去了动物保护中心——
Wait, you went to animal humane to also track down the cat?
等等，你也去了动物保护中心追踪那只猫？
Well, to see if she had been there.
嗯，看看她是否去过那里。
OK. OK.
好吧。好吧。
And nobody knew anything about her or the cat. And so I just, "OK," and I just left. And then I photographed the outside.
没有人知道关于她或猫的任何消息。所以我只是，“好吧，”我就离开了。然后我拍了外面的照片。
So Jessamyn goes home to New Mexico, but she just can't let this go. She's still dealing with the fallout, fighting with Hertz and a few other places over bills. And she decides to do a bunch of things that most of us would not do.
所以杰萨敏回到了新墨西哥州，但她就是无法放下这件事。她仍在应对后果，与赫兹和其他几个地方为了账单而抗争。她决定做很多我们大多数人不会做的事情。
First, Jessamyn sends a letter to Erin's address saying, basically, I know what you did, and here's what it's done to me. She includes an invoice for $1,200, the total cost of her roundtrip flight to California combined with an hourly rate for her time.
首先，杰萨敏寄了一封信到艾琳的地址，基本意思是，我知道你做了什么，这就是它对我造成的影响。她附上了一张1200美元的账单，这是她往返加州的旅费总额加上她时间的小时费率。
And then months later, Jessamyn finds herself back in San Francisco for work. And she picks up Erin's trail again. She has a list of old addresses Erin had lived at, maybe 20 of them, that she got from a private investigator.
几个月后，杰萨敏因为工作又回到了旧金山。她再次捡起了艾琳的踪迹。她有一份从私人调查员那里拿到的艾琳住过的旧地址清单，大概有20个。
And she starts going from place to place, visiting Erin's old apartments. At one point, Jessamyn pulls up to this gorgeous building overlooking the Bay Bridge. At the time, Jessamyn was seven months pregnant, and she thinks, well, maybe I can use this to my advantage.
她开始从一个地方到另一个地方，访问艾琳的旧公寓。有一次，杰萨敏把车停在那栋可以俯瞰海湾大桥的华丽建筑前。当时，杰萨敏怀了七个月身孕，她想，嗯，也许我可以利用这一点为自己谋利。
I went to the front desk, the security officer. And was like, hey, as you can see, I'm pregnant. I really have to go to the bathroom. I'm looking for my cousin, Erin Hart. But I need to use a restroom first. Do you mind?
我去了前台，那个保安。就像，嘿，你看，我怀孕了。我真的需要去趟洗手间。我在找我的表妹艾琳·哈特。但我得先去趟洗手间。你介意吗？
And she was like, Erin Hart? Yeah, I know her. She used to live here. The woman actually knew her boyfriend at the time. And she's like, now I don't know for sure, and it's just gossip. But I had heard that she had had several thousand dollars of his possessions or whatever that she took off with and never came back. And I was like, oh, wow. OK, jeez. And she's like, well, you know Erin, or whatever. And I was like, oh yeah, totally.
她就像，艾琳·哈特？是的，我认识她。她过去住在这里。那个女人实际上认识她当时的男朋友。她说，现在我不敢确定，这只是闲话。但我听说她拿走了他几千美元的财物之类的东西，然后就再也没回来。我说，哦，哇。好吧，天哪。她说，嗯，你知道艾琳，或者别的什么。我说，哦，是啊，完全知道。
Erin's old boyfriend didn't live there anymore. So Jessamyn took a few pictures inside the building and then moved on to the other addresses. All of them were dead ends.
艾琳的旧男朋友不再住那里了。所以杰萨敏在楼里拍了几张照，然后继续去其他地址。所有地址都是死胡同。
I mean, is there any part of you that is kind of feeling like a creep?
我的意思是，你心里有没有一点觉得像个怪胎的感觉？
I knew it was cra-- like, I knew that it was not healthy. I did know that. But I could not let it go as just something that someone did to me that I had no control over.
我知道这很怪——我知道这不健康。我确实知道。但我不能就这样把它放下，作为别人对我做的、我无法控制的事情。
Jessamyn hates feeling like she's lost control. And whenever it happens, ever since she was a teenager, she's dealt with it the same sort of way.
杰萨敏讨厌失去控制的感觉。无论何时发生这种情况，自从她十几岁以来，她处理的方式都一样。
When she was around 11, her dad abandoned the family-- her mom and her three younger siblings. Then they lost their house. And for a while, they all lived in a van with their cat and dog. Her dad, he did some pretty extreme things.
当她大概11岁时，她爸爸抛弃了这个家庭——她妈妈和三个更小的兄弟姐妹。然后他们失去了房子。有一段时间，他们全家住在一辆装着猫和狗的面包车里。她爸爸，他做了一些非常极端的事情。
My dad tried to have me kidnapped.
我爸爸试图绑架我。
He tried to kidnap you or sent someone?
他试图绑架你还是派人？
He tried to have someone come and kidnap me at my school, and then again later, in a park. And my family, we ended up going for some time up to Canada so that he couldn't find us.
他试图让人来学校绑架我，后来又在公园里试了一次。我的家人，我们最终去加拿大待了一段时间，这样他就找不到我们了。
Later, Jessamyn's mom got really sick. And suddenly, she found herself taking care of her entire family. At some point, as a way to deal with all the chaos, she started taking pictures-- things like an ambulance driving her mom away, screaming matches between her sisters, trash strewn all over their trailer home.
后来，杰萨敏的妈妈病得很重。突然间，她发现自己在照顾整个家庭。在某种程度上，作为处理所有混乱的一种方式，她开始拍照——比如救护车把她妈妈带走，她姐妹之间的尖叫争吵，到处是垃圾的拖车房。
She'd methodically document what she was going through, and it gave her a sense of control. She continued to use her camera that way as an adult. At one point, eight years ago, she had a brief scare that reminded her of her dad, a random incident where she wondered if he was following her again.
她有条不紊地记录下她所经历的一切，这给了她一种控制感。成年后她继续用那种方式使用她的相机。有一次，八年前，她有一次短暂的恐慌，让她想起了她爸爸，一次偶然的事件，她怀疑他是否又在跟踪她。
From that night on, I had it in my head I wanted to find him. But I didn't want to find him and talk to him.
从那天晚上起，我就想找到他。但我不想找到他并和他交谈。
What's the thing that you wanted?
你想要的东西是什么？
I just-- I wanted to see him. I wanted to first just find him. I just wanted to know if I could find him, so I did. I did a bunch of searching and background checks and Google stuff. And he was about three and a half hours north of where I lived.
我只是——我想看看他。我想首先只是找到他。我只是想知道我能不能找到他，所以我做到了。我做了大量的搜索、背景调查和谷歌搜索。他在离我住的地方大约三个半小时北边的地方。
Jessamyn was living in Oakland at the time. And her dad was just north of her, living in a condo on the Mendocino coast. She started making covert trips up there.
杰萨敏当时住在奥克兰。她爸爸就在她北边，住在门多西诺海岸的一套公寓里。她开始对他进行秘密访问。
And she never knew how to explain this to her friends. So she kept it simple and told them, oh, I'm going to spend the weekend with my dad, which technically was true. It's just that she did it wearing a blonde wig, and from a distance.
她从来不知道如何向朋友解释这一点。所以她把它简化了，告诉他们，哦，我要去和我爸爸过周末，这在技术上是真的。只是她戴着金发假发，并且保持距离。
Well, I had a telephoto lens and was really far away. I was out in the woods. I could get a mile or so away if I needed to.
好吧，我有一个长焦镜头，离得非常远。我在树林里。如果需要，我可以离一英里左右。
What did you see?
你看到了什么？
He was on the deck. He was out for a walk. He would go to the gym, taking out the trash.
他在甲板上。他出来散步。他会去健身房，去倒垃圾。
And he never saw you?
他从来没看到你？
No, no.
不，没有。
When you're stalking your dad, or you're following your dad--
当你跟踪你爸爸的时候，或者你跟着你爸爸的时候——
I was observing him from a distance.
我是在远处观察他。
Observing him. And so what did that feel like?
观察他。那感觉如何？
It felt really good to see him, and him not know I was there.
看到他，而他不知道我在那里，感觉真的很好。
Because why?
为什么？
Because I had some knowledge about who he was and what he was doing. It was like a one-way mirror. I could see in, and he couldn't see me. And it felt like I had some kind of power.
因为我对他是谁、他在做什么有一些了解。这就像一面单向镜。我可以看到里面，而他看不到我。这让我觉得我拥有某种权力。
I don't know much about the identity theft business. But I'm guessing that the ideal target does not own a camera that can photograph you from a mile away. Two years after Jessamyn got that phone call from the police, she was still trying to track Erin down. And in February 2013, her private investigator let her know that he found Erin. She was back in jail and about to be released.
我对身份盗窃业务了解不多。但我猜理想的目标不会拥有能从一英里外拍到你的相机。杰萨敏接到警察打来的那个电话两年后，她还在试图追踪艾琳。2013年2月，她的私人调查员告诉她他找到了艾琳。她又进了监狱，即将被释放。
Jessamyn went with him to a jail in downtown San Francisco. She brought a telephoto lens and a video camera. And the two of them sat around in his SUV for hours, waiting. Her PI had a contact who told him Erin might come out the back.
杰萨敏和他在旧金山市中心的一个监狱里。她带了一个长焦镜头和一个摄像机。他们俩在SUV里坐了几个小时，等待。她的私人调查员有一个联系人告诉他艾琳可能会从后门出来。
She's gonna come out the back here soon.
她很快就要从后门出来了。
Hopefully.
希望如此。
One by one, people were coming out. And the entire time, I'm just photographing. I had this lens pointed at the door. And terrified that she's not going to come out. She's not going to come out. We're not going to find her. And we see her.
人们一个接一个地出来。整个过程中，我一直在拍照。我把这个镜头对准了门。害怕她不会出来。她不会出来。我们不会找到她。然后我们看到了她。
Here she comes.
她来了。
Here she comes. Is that her?
她来了。是她吗？
Yep.
是。
Yes, that's her.
是的，是她。
Grab the envelope. OK, we got her.
拿上信封。好了，抓到她了。
Erin Hart walked right past their car. She had a couple bags hanging off her shoulder. And she was dressed, Jessamyn thought, like she was going to a nightclub-- tight black shirt, shiny pants, and wedge boots.
艾琳·哈特从他们的车旁走过。她肩上挂着两个包。杰萨敏觉得她的打扮就像要去夜总会——紧身黑衬衫、亮面裤子和坡跟靴。
Immediately I thought, oh my gosh, we do kind of look similar. She was a similar build to me, which is sort of tallish, 5'7", 5'8", but fuller figured, wider hips. And I could see that she had a roundish face, like I do.
我立刻想，天哪，我们看起来确实有点像。她体型和我相似，属于那种高挑，5英尺7英寸，5英尺8英寸，但体型丰满，臀部更宽。我能看出她有一张圆脸，就像我一样。
And she has this bright orange hair. And I just thought of my days in my teenage years dying my hair that exact orange, this super bright orange. And I just felt this uncanny connection to her. I really did. And then from there on, for the next several hours, was just, you know, adrenaline.
而且她有一头亮橙色的头发。我只是想到我十几岁时把头发染成那种精确橙色的日子，那种超亮的橙色。我真的觉得我与她有一种奇特的联系。我真的觉得。从那时起，接下来的几个小时里，就是肾上腺素。
She's on foot. She's on foot.
她正在步行。她在步行。
OK.
好的。
Let me call Jerel and tell him.
让我给杰瑞尔打电话告诉他。
They had two other PIs working with them in a separate car. They all trailed Erin, whose first stop was a convenience store, where she went in to buy cigarettes and a lighter. She hung outside for a few minutes smoking, and then got on a public bus.
他们还有两名私人调查员在另一辆车里为他们工作。他们都跟踪了艾琳，艾琳的第一站是一家便利店，她进去买了香烟和打火机。她在外面抽了会儿烟，然后上了一辆公共汽车。
(WHISPERING) Where is she going?
（耳语）她要去哪儿？
She's going to Goodwill.
她要去好运来旧货店。
Erin got off right in front of a Goodwill store and walked in.
艾琳直接在好运来旧货店门前下车走了进去。
Right away, Pete says, jump out and go in there. Go after her. And I was like, oh, should I talk to her? You know, I'm thinking, oh, OK.
皮特立刻说，跳出去进去。跟上她。我说，哦，我应该和她交谈吗？你知道，我在想，哦，好的。
He's like, no, no, no. Don't talk to her. Just go in, get your photographs. Get a good look at her. Just go, go, go, go, go. And so I'm jumping out, like freaking out, like, oh my god, he's just leaving me here with her. Like, what do I-- and then I see Nate and Jerel in there.
他说，不，不，不。不要和她交谈。只要进去，拍你的照。好好看看她。走，走，走，走，走。所以我跳出来，就像吓坏了，就像，我的天，他只是把我留在这儿和她在一起。就像，我该做什么——然后我看到内特和杰瑞尔在里面。
The other PIs.
其他的私人调查员。
Yeah. I'm like, OK. So I'm looking at them for cues. And they're not remotely giving me any kind of cues. And then I just go for it, and I go up to her. And I don't say anything to her. I just stand right across the rack of clothes in the Goodwill from her as she's going through, pulling clothes out, looking, changing her mind.
是的。我想，好的。所以我看着他们寻找信号。他们一点也没给我任何信号。然后我就冲了进去，走到了她身边。我没跟她说任何话。我只是站在好运来商店里她面前的一排衣服架子对面，她正在翻找，拉出衣服，看着，改变主意。
Very expressive-- like, oh, no, I would never wear that. I could kind of hear in my mind what she might be thinking from like her expression. And I'm at an angle where I feel like she can't really tell what I'm doing. Like, maybe I'm just checking my email or something, and I'm just looking at my phone. And I take some photos of her.
非常生动——就像，哦，不，我永远不会穿那件。从她的表情中，我能听到我心里她在想什么。我站在一个我觉得她真的看不出我在做什么的角度。就像，也许我只是在查看电子邮件之类的，而我只是在看手机。我拍了一些她的照片。
But how nervous are you? I mean, literally, now you're face to face.
但你有多紧张？我的意思是，实际上，现在你们面对面了。
I'm shaking. I'm very nervous, definitely. And I think there's a part of me that is still thinking, I could just talk to her right now. Erin. Hey, Erin. I could just say that.
我在发抖。我很紧张，当然。我认为我内心深处有一部分仍然在想，我现在就可以和她交谈。艾琳。嘿，艾琳。我可以那样说。
I could hear myself saying, Erin Hart, I know you probably don't recognize me. I know you don't know me. But I am Laurel Jessamyn Lovell, and you used my ID to do a number of things.
我能听到自己说，艾琳·哈特，我知道你可能不认识我。我知道你不认识我。但我叫劳雷尔·杰萨敏·洛弗尔，你用我的证件做了很多事情。
But the power for me was in seeing her without her knowing that I was seeing her. And then she disappears into the dressing room. And that's when the other PI comes over to me and says, she's stealing clothes. And I was like, what?
但对我来说，力量在于看着她而她不知道我在看她。然后她消失在试衣间里。那是另一个私人调查员走过来对我说，她在偷衣服。我说，什么？
I just needed to get out of there. I was overwhelmed. I was feeling really sad for her. And I didn't want to feel sad for her. I wanted to feel angry at her.
我只需要离开那里。我不知所措。我为她感到难过。我不想为她感到难过。我想对她生气。
It was hard to maintain the anger, because she was looking at Erin and remembering things she'd done when she was young and her family was broke.
很难保持愤怒，因为她在看着艾琳，回忆起她年轻且家庭破产时做过的事情。
I had shoplifted, like, nice cheese. Or like, I literally stole arugula. Like, things that I thought and associated with class, middle to upper middle class. And I think that's what really was giving me this sympathy for Erin Hart was I could identify, in a way, with the desire to be someone else.
我偷过像好的奶酪之类的东西。或者像，我真的偷了芝麻菜。就像，我关联到阶级，中产阶级到中上阶级的东西。我想这正是真正让我对艾琳·哈特产生同情心的原因，因为我可以从某种程度上认同想成为别人的欲望。
I could see how a path in my life could have led to my being in that moment. I really could. But it was, I guess, a little disappointing. I guess it was a little like, oh, I kind of wanted it to be like she was a criminal and did something bad to me.
我能看到我生命中的一条道路是如何导致我在那一刻出现在那里的。我真的能。但我想，这有点令人失望。我想有点像，哦，我本来希望她是个罪犯，对我做了什么坏事。
Yeah.
是的。
And it just wasn't that. None of that satisfaction of "I got her." It was just this weird transition. And anger was starting to be sort of replaced with empathy.
而事实并非如此。那种“我抓到她了”的满足感一点都没有。这只是那种奇怪的转变。愤怒开始被同情所取代。
What Jessamyn did next doesn't sound empathetic at all when you first hear about it. But for Jessamyn, it was the logical end of research. She went through the hundreds of images she'd taken, and she put together a gallery exhibit. It had surveillance shots of Erin, the court summons, police reports, bills, and pictures of places where her ID had been used.
杰萨敏接下来做的事情当你第一次听到时一点也不让人同情。但对杰萨敏来说，这是研究的逻辑终点。她翻看了她拍的数百张照片，并将它们整理成一个画廊展览。里面有艾琳的监控截图、法庭传票、警方报告、账单以及她的证件被使用的地点的图片。
She'd done this once before with the surveillance photos she took of her dad. In fact, her wallet was stolen while she was setting up that exhibit, which is what sent her down the rabbit hole of trying to find Erin in the first place. She called the new show, "Dear Erin Hart."
她在拍摄她爸爸的监控照片时做过一次。事实上，她的钱包是在她筹备那个展览时被偷的，这正是她陷入追踪艾琳的兔洞的起因。她把新展览命名为“亲爱的艾琳·哈特”。
And one of the items on display was a sealed letter in a Plexiglas box. She asked the people at the gallery to give it to Erin if she ever showed up there. It wasn't a dramatic letter, just a way of telling Erin that she'd been looking for her and wanted to talk.
展品中有一封放在有机玻璃盒里的密封信。她要求画廊的人如果艾琳出现的话就把信交给她。那不是一封戏剧性的信，只是一种告诉艾琳她在找她并想谈谈的方式。
Jessamyn didn't see putting Erin's name and photos out in public as revenge. But not everyone saw it that way.
杰萨敏并不认为把艾琳的名字和照片公开是一种报复。但并不是所有人都这么看。
If you were a victim of identity theft, would you consider tracking down the thief and turning the tables?
如果你是身份盗窃的受害者，你会考虑追踪小偷并反击吗？
This is from the Today Show.
这是来自《今日秀》。
In an act some have described as revenge, Lovell followed and photographed the woman who stole her wallet, and then her identity.
在一些人描述为复仇的行为中，洛弗尔追踪并拍摄了那个偷走她钱包，然后偷走她身份的人。
I reached out to Erin Hart through her probation officer to talk about all this. I sent a couple of emails listing everything Jessamyn says about her. But Erin never got back to me. So I couldn't verify whether she was responsible for bills Jessamyn got from Hertz and Whole Foods, or any of the unpaid parking tickets and tolls, or whether she shoplifted from Goodwill or stole from her boyfriend.
我通过艾琳·哈特的缓刑官联系了她谈论这一切。我发了几封电子邮件，列出了杰萨敏关于她的一切说法。但艾琳从没回复我。所以我无法核实她是否要为杰萨敏收到的来自赫兹和全食超市的账单，或任何未付的停车罚单和通行费负责，或者她是否从好运来偷窃，或者偷了她男朋友的东西。
So Erin secretly posed as Jessamyn, and Jessamyn secretly photographed Erin. Jessamyn admits it's an uncomfortable thing that they have in common. Each of them is willing to invade someone else's privacy to get what they want.
所以艾琳秘密地冒充杰萨敏，而杰萨敏秘密地拍摄了艾琳。杰萨敏承认这是一件不舒服的事情，也是她们共同点。她们每个人都愿意侵犯别人的隐私以得到她们想要的东西。
Miki Meek is one of the producers of our show. Like I said earlier, today's show was first broadcast a couple years ago. Since then, Jessamyn has become a licensed private investigator. She's taken courses in self-defense, weapons training, research. She says her skills are in high demand.
米基·米克是我们节目的制片人之一。像我之前说过的，今天的节目是几年前第一次广播的。从那时起，杰萨敏成了一名持证私人调查员。她选修了自卫、武器训练、研究课程。她说她的技能需求量很大。
We thought we would end today's program on an airplane. At some point in putting together this week's show, it occurred to us that an overnight flight really is just like this huge bed, with hundreds of people all together, dreaming different dreams.
我们想以在飞机上结束今天的节目。在准备这一周节目的某个时候，我们想到一次过夜飞行确实就像这张巨大的床，有数百人在一起，梦想着不同的梦想。
And we asked people on two different flights like this to tell us their dreams, and their daydreams, and their hopes and dreams. One of our staff was actually on a red eye flight herself and got on the plane's PA system to explain the premise.
我们要求人们在两架这样的飞机上告诉我们他们的梦想、他们的白日梦，以及他们的希望和梦想。我们的一名员工实际上就在一架红眼航班上，并使用了飞机的PA系统来解释这个前提。
May I have your attention, please, ladies and gentlemen? My name is Stephanie Foo.
请注意，女士们先生们。我的名字是斯蒂芬妮·富。
Somehow, being on the PA system, she started talking like a flight attendant.
不知怎么的，在使用PA系统时，她开始像空乘人员那样说话。
I am doing a story about this flight.
我正在做一个关于这个航班的故事。
David Weinberg and Jessica Ament recorded people as well. Here are some of them.
大卫·温伯格和杰西卡·阿门也录制了人们的声音。这里是其中的一些。
I was dreaming about old fashioned TV antennas. And then at one point, I felt like I was shaking. And I'm sure it was because the plane was shaking. But I was trying to adjust the antenna.
我梦见老式电视天线。然后在某个时刻，我觉得我在颤抖。我敢肯定那是因为飞机在颤抖。但我试着调整天线。
I was dreaming about-- I was in a hot air balloon. And I was yelling for my dog. "Hey, Katie, I'm up here."
我梦见——我坐在热气球里。我正在大喊我的狗。“嘿，凯蒂，我在上面。”
Sitting there, semi-lucid, I was thinking of the horned puffins swimming underwater, and how the little bubbles come out of their feathers when they're swimming. And then I thought of them as going along in space and creating stars, and then diving into the center of the galaxy.
坐在那里，半清醒，我想着角海雀在水下游泳，以及当它们游泳时小气泡是如何从它们的羽毛中冒出来的。然后我想到它们在太空中穿行，创造恒星，然后潜入星系中心。
That's really trippy.
那真的很迷幻。
Yeah.
是啊。
Were you medicated at all?
你服药了吗？
No, not at all. [LAUGHS]
没有，完全没有。[笑]
I had a total nightmare. I was backing down a hill out of a garage with a friend in a VW bus. And we lost control of it and went down the hill. And my friend turned to me and said, you know, I will never forgive you for this.
我做了一个噩梦。我和一个朋友坐在一辆大众巴士里倒下一座山，出了车库。我们失去了控制，冲下了山。我朋友转过来对我说，你知道，我永远不会原谅你。
Everybody says, why would you want to go to New York? Ew, it's so big. And why? And I'm like, because you see all these things on television. I have always wanted to experience a cab ride in New York City. We're going to do it all. We're going to do it all.
每个人都说，你为什么要来纽约？呃，它太大了。为什么？我就像，因为你在电视上看到了所有这些东西。我一直想体验纽约市的出租车旅行。我们要做完这一切。我们要做完这一切。
My daughter's about to have a baby. So I don't know if dream's exactly the right word, but a lot of hopes. It's her first baby, my first grandbaby. Just to put it simply, I definitely didn't live up to my responsibility as her father. And I had not been a regular part of her life up until she was nine. I blew it. So I'm definitely not going to make the same mistakes that I made with her. I feel like I've been given a second chance.
我女儿快要生孩子了。所以我不知道梦想是否是准确的词，但有很多希望。这是她的第一个孩子，我的第一个孙子。简单地说，我绝对没有履行我作为父亲的责任。在她9岁之前，我没有定期出现在她的生活中。我搞砸了。所以我绝对不会犯我以前犯过的同样的错误。我觉得我得到了第二次机会。
[MUSIC - "SAME BED, DIFFERENT DREAMS," BY JOHN HOWARD]
[音乐 - “同床异梦”，由约翰·霍华德演唱]
Our program was produced today by Zoe Chace and me with Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Joe Richman, Robyn Semien Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike.
我们的节目今天由佐伊·蔡斯和我制作，还有肖恩·科尔、斯蒂芬妮·富、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、布莱恩·里德、乔·里奇曼、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。
Senior producer for today's program is Julie Snyder. Editing help from Joel Lovell. Research help from Michelle Harris and Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
今天节目的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。编辑帮助来自乔尔·洛弗尔。研究帮助来自米歇尔·哈里斯和克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉。音乐帮助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗伯·格迪斯。
Special thanks today to Clinton Cargil, Sam Greenspan, Sarah Stieger, Ian Shapira, Alaska Airlines, Gonzalo Martinez de Vedia, and The Worker Justice Center of New York, Antonio Cericido of Latino USA, Jeff Singer, Chris Crawford, and Cece Chen.
今天特别感谢克林顿·卡吉尔、萨姆·格林斯潘、莎拉·斯蒂格、伊恩·夏皮拉、阿拉斯加航空公司、贡萨洛·马丁内斯·德·维迪亚和纽约工人司法中心、Latino USA的安东尼奥·塞里西多、杰夫·辛格、克里斯·克劳福德和塞西·陈。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX传送给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our programs co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who, of course, stopped by the office. He's wearing the same outfit today that he wears every single day.
像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他当然顺便来办公室看了看。他今天穿的衣服和他每天穿的一模一样。
Tight black shirt, shiny pants, and wedge boots.
紧身黑衬衫、亮面裤子和坡跟靴。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多关于这个美国生活的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "ONLY IN MY DREAMS," BY DEBBIE GIBSON]
[音乐 - “只在我的梦中”，由黛比·吉布森演唱]
(SINGING) Don't turn the record over. Drop the needle at the start. And put your hand back on my shoulder. I'm dreaming, dreaming away the time.
（歌唱）不要翻唱片。从头放下针。把你的手放回我的肩膀上。我在梦想，梦想着消磨时光。